Olá pessoal aqui Dr Alan Machado duta
para mais um vídeo muito obrigado por tá
ligado aqui no canal a maioria dos
adultos atinge o pico de massa muscular
entre os 30 e os 40 depois desse ponto
você começa a ter uma perda gradual de
massa muscular e pode continuar um curso
constante e descendente até a velice
essa perda de massa muscular força e
função relacionado à idade tem um nome é
sarcopenia e pode acontecer mais rápido
do que você pensa pessoas fisicamente
inativas Podem perder de 3 a 5% da sua
massa muscular por década após os 30
anos então essa condição pode levar a
uma diminuição da força da mobilidade da
Independência além de aumentar o risco
de quedas e fraturas a massa muscular
não é apenas essencial paraa mobilidade
a realização de atividades diárias mas
também desempenho um papel crucial na
regulação do metabolismo na manutenção
do equilíbrio hormonal e na prevenção de
doenças crônicas e o que que você pode
fazer então para evitar essa perda de
massa muscular o que que você pode fazer
a partir de hoje a atividade física
existe uma importância essencial no
Exercício especialmente os de
resistência ou de força com musculação
pilates exercícios funcionais eles são
fundamentais para combater a perda de
massa muscular estimulam o crescimento
muscular melhoram a força a resistência
aumentam a capacidade aeróbica outra
coisa pessoal fundamental é ter um
estilo de vida ativo adotar um estilo de
vida ativo sem sedentarismo são Passos
fundamentais essenciais para prevenir a
sarcopenia a inclusão de atividades
físicas regulares manutenção do peso
saudável são vitais pra saúde muscular
em geral também a alimentação o papel
dela é muito importante comer mais
proteína escolhas inteligentes aumentar
a gestão de proteínas é fundamental ela
é crucial paraa reparação e crescimento
muscular adultos mais velhos precisam de
1,2 a 1,5 g de proteína por qugo de peso
corporal por dia então optar por fontes
de proteínas ricas em leucina que é um
aminoácido essencial pro crescimento
muscular É sim uma escolha bem
inteligente vamos falar então de algumas
fontes de proteína de alta qualidade o
frango que ciscou a vaca com meu
pasto peixes frango orgânico ovos
caipiras produtos láctos integrais são
todos ricos em proteínas de alta
qualidade que dão apoio suportam o
crescimento muscular é fundamental
também estar ligado no equilíbrio
hormonal é importantíssimo monitorar os
seus níveis de hormônios Então porque
desequilíbrios hormonais podem afetar a
massa muscular então avaliação e o
ajuste de níveis hormonais como
testosterona estradiol hormônio
crescimento dhea o
dehidroepiandrosterona
então o consumo excessivo de álcool o
uso de tabaco pode contribuir paraa
perda de massa muscular e a deterioração
da saúde geral então limite o uso de
álcool e cesse o uso de tabaco são
medidas importantes para preservar sua
massa muscular e vamos falar aqui um
pouquinho de suplementação o que você
deve tomar o que que eu indico acima dos
50 anos de idade para essa finalidade os
ômega-3 tem vários benefícios então aos
grassos ômega-3 tem efeitos
antiinflamatórios podem melhorar a
síntese de proteínas musculares além de
oferecer benefícios paraa saúde
cardiovascular do coração e saúde
cerebral cognitiva as fontes incluem
peixes gordurosos óleo de linhaça
suplementos de óleo de peixe também não
podemos esquecer de dizer sobre a
importância da vitamina D A vitamina D
de dado ela é fundamental na verdade é
um hormônio importante íssimo pra saúde
ó e pra saúde e função muscular também
dá um suporte fundamental ao sistema
imune então a deficiência de vitamina D
é comum em pessoas mais velhas e tem que
ser observado tem que ser atentamente
visto isso porque ela pode contribuir
para a perda de força muscular e maior
risco de quedas também podemos utilizar
os famosos aminoácidos essenciais são
suplementos de aminoácidos Como o
próprio nome indica essenciais são os
nove que o corpo não produz
especialmente aqueles enriquecidos com
leucina eles são eficazes no estímulo a
síntese de proteínas musculares que são
importantes paraa recuperação e o
crescimento muscular um estudo de 2010
mostrou que a ingestão de aminoácidos
essenciais que sejam enriquecidos com
leucina estimulam a síntese de proteínas
musculares de forma semelhante tanto em
jovens quant indivíduos idosos e a
famosa creatina que já falamos várias
vezes aqui no canal a atina é muito
importante ela melhora a força melhora a
performance durante o exercício
contribui pro ganho de massa muscular é
benéfica pra saúde cerebral muita gente
não sabe disso e pode ajudar na energia
diária a dose de 3 a 5 G uma vez ao dia
dependendo da sua massa muscular e Sexo
e a Glutamina Glutamina também é muito
famosa é outra aminoácido que muita
gente conhece mas ela não é tão
importante assim para o ganho direto de
massa mas ela vai dar suporte a
recuperação muscular reduzindo o risco
de perda muscular auxilia na saúde
intestinal hoje mesmo eu atendi uma
paciente aqui que resolveu a constipação
Só usando Glutamina Então esse
aminoácido também vai ajudar a melhorar
a absorção de nutrientes essenciais pro
crescimento muscular pessoal Muito
obrigado pela sua atenção é sempre bom
estar aqui com vocês nessa troca gostosa
aqui de informações um grande abraço um
beijo no seu coração você é feira m